he everybody you know it's not the show
there's no show this week but thank you
for joining us there's there going to be
a big show next week yeah Halloween man
I know I know what I'm going to be I
know what I'm going to be also I cannot
wait to show you same uh but this week
we're here to help dudy launch the new
clips Channel we got a Clips Channel now
yeah dude that's cool yeah man I I've
wanted that for my own uh purposes yeah
to watch Clips so we hope that you guys
all uh enjoy some clips and [__] and I I
past that I don't know what the [__]
we're doing here to be quite honest
welcome to the historic launch of the
dudy clips Channel call me dudy will and
Chad thanks for helping me get this
thing off the ground the dudy clips
channel is your One-Stop shop for Stone
Cold Steve Austin reads wil sasso's
childhood diary Robert Dair Crow's Crow
etry infomania Tom Haynes movie trailers
and everything else we've done over the
past year and a half all edited into
convenient easyto find Clips will Chad I
want to give you a small taste of things
you'll be able to find on the clips
Channel this is the dudy clips Channel
begin okay oh [__] I guess we're going
to watch some using all of the data I
have absorbed from text messages and
emails you and the astonishing friends
you grew up with I was able to recreate
your childhood diary you must now read
the passages I have selected in the
voice of Stone Cold Steve Austin this is
Stone Cold Steve Austin reads will
sasso's childhood diary began wow dude
okay
is this in your thing look how
frustrated I am see this is before I
really went to D like I want to shake
your hand diary and I sort of feel like
because as as you said this is the first
time that dudy has ever laid out what
our look assignments are at the
beginning of the show I'm a little I'm a
little scared that this is the last
thing like maybe I I'm not trying to
predict anything I'm just saying that
it's listen I'm just going to say you're
telling me that you didn't have a child
the diary I believe of course I did not
I you know what I used to do I used to
make little one-off comic books like I
would take take a notebook and fill it
with paper and I had and I had remember
oh this is interesting this is for in I
started this in the sixth grade I okay
so I'm prattling on about making
whatever I did I used to draw pictures
in the sixth grade and now I'm talking
about that Long Island January 6 uh but
uh youe it's interesting for me to see
how weirded out I am by dud and what dud
does called super cluck as a chicken uh
yeah it was a chicken and it was just
super cluck and he had like a Superman
outfit on and then he had a friend man
this is the first Stone Cold Steve
Austin but I never had a childhood diary
let's this is interesting CU I was
talking about this last
week now let's just take a would I have
done this differently you didn't have a
childhood diary as dudy said it made
this from emails and text messages that
you currently have or have had in the
past with your check childhood friends
astonishing childhood friends sorry
foret yeah all my my buddies and stuff
you know when you're texting your
friends um uh let's see what we got I
got this in this okay all right I so
should I seem to be a willing
participant and what's happening god
dude this is pretty all right all right
for [__]
sake September
1990 dear diary first day of football
practice got a good team I'm still the
best I was the best in the fifth grade I
was the best in the sixth grade and I
was the best in the seventh grade I'm
the
best let me okay all right holy [__]
first day football practice got a good
team I'm still the best I was best in
the fifth grade I was best in the sixth
grade I was best in the seventh grade
I'm the best in the eighth grade I don't
think that I was the best football
player come
underestimat neither else the best
neither would anyone else says that
twice that's weird but besides me we got
some other good [__] guys we got Odum
Adams can I say this out these are I
don't know who these people are I got we
got we got odm's Adam Cantrell we got
Proctor Rector cell we got Hodes Bridges
y can't forget about your godamn Wheeler
Weaver baits we got [__] Perry
Terry Pope and we got Sut and duton cop
Lind and thank God coach Vance seems to
have his head on straight again he's a
lot better since that [__]
accident okay what that wasn't my my my
high school football coach it almost
have like a poetic rhythm to the names
that it say I don't know who coach Vance
is coach you didn't have a coach Vance
no I had coach Dale Cy he's still did Cy
have some kind of accident still in my
life uh great guy hav haven't spoken to
him in a while actually what did any
coach of yours ever have an accident
nope coach site never had an accident
okay he never uh no not not that I can
uh not that I can man I am looking at
myself and I am so bewildered by what's
happening I can tell I'm like no dude I
remember this first one was like believe
this was in any way accurate to your
actual child the premise of this like
comedically was very interesting to me
the best and I thought it was written
well I wasn't the best yeah no right
away by the way sorry that I'm yammering
all over this go check out the clips
Channel that's what we're here to do
we're here to provide a
reaction here watch look of the
league equated mimic big huge Farm
boys big huge Farm boys on the football
team I can tell just by watching the way
I'm doing this I am really trying to
wrap my head around what the [__] we are
doing here with this with our pal D it's
very interesting to see the early 25th
1990 dear diary Halloween's right around
the [__] corner all Hallow's Eve
devil's night I got invited to a bunch
of [__] parties all the big
ones Renee Malone Charlie Reynolds
Tabitha
MDS Dante little legs Jibber
Pras [__] St trillo bites [__]
trillo I even got invited to [__]
Greg King cage party oh weird and that's
very weird because that's Greg Cade was
the guy who blew his [__] out of my
junior high okay so dudy is and I wrot
our child into one childh D's had some
uh dudy heart if you know what I'm
saying dudy dudy is coming home from
work did you know any full big full
briefcase tell asking his wife where
dinner is did you know anyone named
Dante little Le or Jibber Prolia let me
answer that with a a question of my own
do you know anybody named Dante little
leg no little leg is not a real ass name
and
jimber
not Trad making up these weird
nam I would say is like in this C grety
get to wear a helmet I get to hold a
[__] hocky stick all night I get to
make dinosaur
noises what is happening never have to
go to the bathroom that was a legit What
because what can legally drive and buy
beer immune to vamp Empires these are
all wi Gretzky things yeah those are all
descriptions of wi grety fros of ET
aliens are hot right now have a
repeatable [__] catchphrase don't
need a
costume I'm going to the clips Channel
after this to actually get a good
night's sleep run faster than a car see
this again to vampires oh I'm so
confused guess I got someing to do were
you did you ever go to a Halloween party
is Wayne Gretzky or ET no I loved Wayne
Gretzky and ET as much as any other kid
who grew up in the 80s but no Chad I
never [__] oh my God was Wayne
Gretzky known for making dinosaur noises
no I don't believe so he was known uh
mostly for being one of the greatest
hockey players if not the greatest
hockey player of all time great one they
and uh and hanging out in his office
Gretzky's office cool where he would
hang out in the back behind the net
swirl around there and
uh
ah well that's really [__] up
November I can't get over how young
November 1st 19 year or something ago
dear [__] diary [__] J ha
now yeah I get it life's taking his
[__] Jibber braal you put Dante
little leg to shame this year little leg
was so humiliated he might not even
throw a Halloween party next year I
[__] wouldn't if I was him I'd take
some time time to get my [__] head on
straight braal you had live music
dancing sodas chips scary movies fake
spiders on the toilet lizard hand on
your head Dracula following you home
nightmares tired the next day can't do
your work get expelled forget who you
used to be move to a new [__] City
fake name new job new family start one
start over no one's wise shelter kids
from the idea of Halloween once they got
to grade school their friends tell them
anyway this one's insane they want to go
trick treating this is Relentless
discourage lose the fight like this is
funny to me but I would say D's writing
has gotten way better that gibberish I
don't know see right there I'm saying
that this is gibberish although a bad
time at one of these parties or
something well it was see you're
saying's a story or Dante little leg no
I'm sorry I do not uh know either of
those men November I feel like now I do
know Dante pilion or Dante little
and much more we didn't even we didn't
anyway did you know T Schubert nope I
didn't know I knew our dear pal Taran
Kum ended up being voicing jber Pia okay
Tanya Schubert asked me to the fall
social today I asked her why she said
she liked how funny I was now I got to
be honest here for a second I'm really
funny like really really funny this is
all in caps with lots of e and A's that
seems like something you would have
written in a childhood diary to me
actually that was that would have been
something that I absolutely would have
said in high school I'm very funny I'm
definitely the funniest kid at Delta
secondary school that's literally that's
where I went okay oh excuse me pop soda
hell I'm definitely the funniest [__]
person at Delta secondary teachers
included I know some teachers who would
take issue with that by the way John
southernland comes to mind very funny
guy used to dress up as an ous every
year at our Halloween party and he would
be have an out housee and then it would
say John on it which I think is very
affable for a teacher to to be able to
say his first name I gave that Mr so
much [__] a lot of [__] [__] when
I was a kid felt bad about it but then
uh I saw him I came back to the school
to visit all right get on with it will
geez see this is what I'm going to do
watching the uh watching the Clips
Channel just yell at myself
be every once in a while you got to yell
at yourself that's
aonic you know nice dude he was math
teacher you were really funny that's
[__] hilarious stuff we miss
something hilarious that kind of comedic
genius that I that I this is also like
last week when Arnold was yelling at you
while you're watching stuff are you
trying to watch what you're watching it
made a lot of sense to me know you can't
why are you watching him do this voes
on Stone Cold I really do the [__]
problem is and I told her this I said
Tanya the [__] problem is I can't go
to the [__] dance and if you took
even a second to see past the fact that
I'm funniest guy in Ladner you would
have realize that there's more to me
than just making you laugh I have other
interests and Thursday night I'll be
home watching Survivor Series no I will
not go to the [__] false social with
you T get your [__] head on straight
that's seems likely to me that you
turned down the output that right away
ground running a lot of material yeah
why would Survivor wild building its own
little weird world it's crazy to see
that this is really interesting tell me
you tell me why don't you tell me all
right here's the is this the last one oh
thank God okay
anyway this one December 10th 1990 are
these all from 1990 yeah I think so
December 10th 1990 dear diary you know I
ain't much for poetry but something
changed to me after last this last
Survivor series and that change was due
to one man the only way I can express
what I'm feeling because of that man is
in a poem so here it goes oh this is fun
Undertaker
under here we go Undertaker okay so here
it goes Undertaker take me over this is
a poem yes it wrote a [__] poem dude
Undertaker take me over graveyard sky
and headstone Clover 6'1 and 320 lbs a
giant hat great skills on the mat you
make these other guys look like clowns
Undertaker take me over Paul Bearer is
your promoter Tombstone hellsgate Snake
Eyes last ride from Death Valley don't
meet you in an alley when when I saw
your first match I [__]
cried Undertaker Take Me Over You
Undertaker take me over you're really
hot full disclosure you make quick work
of Coco
beware never broke a smile impeccable
style I would love to see you destroy
Ric Flair Undertaker take me
over wait a
minute you have to do it
why do
I you have to Undertaker take me over
dick so hard I lost composure Undertaker
take me over dick so hard I lost
composure Undertaker take me over dick
so hard I lost
composure [__] oh man [__] that look how
mad you are that was so dumb oh my gosh
okay well that's uh what you can expect
I guess on the clips Channel I loved
rewatching that dude that was brought me
back to when we were first starting to
do this thing and dudy was starting to
kick out these little things and make
these weird worlds with all those
different characters from your Junior
High it's great unbelievable
unbelievable stuff what a very
interesting for me uh in particular
watching uh this right now but uh save
for that uh you know another time we'll
talk about that but for you thank you so
much for hanging out with us in this
little uh short hang we're looking
forward to getting back to it next week
it's going to be Halloween full costume
I know what I got you know what you're
going to wear don't tell me don't tell
me don't tell anybody uh in the meantime
we hope that you will subscribe to the
clips Channel head on over to it the uh
URL the link is in the description to
this video and it will also be on our
link tree uh link tree.com
dudy thank you'all so much and uh we'll
see you next week thanks so much will
and Chad I hope you had as much fun
watching the Clips as I had watching you
watch them I'll be going back through
the dudy catalog every week and dropping
more Clips in the dudy clips channel so
stay tuned and if I didn't say it before
I'm looking very forward to seeing you
both in your beautiful Halloween
costumes next week until then call me
dudy you know what I'm going to do I'm
going to go over to the clips Channel
right now and check out all the clips
that are in the clips Channel at the in
the clips Channel right now because
there's Clips in the Clips in the clips
Channel right now yeah dude there's
Clips in the clips Channel
that's what a Clips hold on dude hold on
dude that's what that's what a Clips
channel has dude Clips if you like d
here's what you
do please tell a friend then rate
review if you like Dy what you
do please tell a friend then R
revie if you like d here what you
do please tell a friend then